my god dave i've heard enough crazy
stuff for one day well we've still got
more because do we have the warning do
we have the warning for the people yes
here's joy behar on the view she's
freaking out over climate change
supporting what the hell is wrong with
y'all don't you see what's happening now
they're waiting for the eiffel tower to
melt
because you know with runway a runway in
england is melting they cannot land the
plane yes on the on
they're waiting for the eiffel tower to
melt i think she butchered a joke
perhaps that she was saying that the
water is going to raise so that
ultimately the sea level will engulf the
eiffel tower then she mentions this
raniere yes there was a hot runway
somewhere in england they don't have any
evidence that any of this has to do with
climate change these are the same crazy
people who 20 years ago 30 years 40
years ago you can look at all of the
headlines in newsweek and time magazine
and elsewhere that the big chill is
coming and we're going to go into a
global freeze and then temperatures went
up slightly and down a little bit more
and also couching all of that is the
idea that if you just gave these people
enough power if you just behaved a
little bit differently if you just used
a little bit of a different bag when you
went to whole foods that somehow the
environment would be okay or that a
bunch of these people who have never
accomplished anything these people who
are not industry leaders these people
who are not thought leaders these people
who are just bureaucrat nonsensical
usurpers of of your time and resources
if they just had more of your time and
resources then they could fix the
environment these people cannot tie
their shoes
okay they cannot tie their shoes they're
just the worst